family means everything we absolutely
love our kids we have so much fun
together the laughter is nearly
continuous I don't know of any other
family that's as much fun as we do well
it's an honor to have you with us what
brings you to Tennessee obviously to do
our debt-free screen the beginning of
our story starts with going to college
and meeting a man who arrived on campus
and his dress blues it was a marine and
it was pretty much over right then
shortly after we were married our first
son Sean was born while we were in the
hospital the nurses kept bringing him
saying he wouldn't stop crying
it turned out after a couple of years we
found out that he indeed had autism and
our journey with sean began and it was a
challenging one
as Sean became more independent is when
we started to see our marriage start to
drop away in the sense that it was we no
longer had this team-building exercise
that we were working on there was never
a time where there wasn't some kind of
crusade going on whether it was school
whether it was moving whether it was a
military deployment we were always had
some kind of crisis that we had to deal
with after about 15 20 years it got to a
point where there were no more Crusades
the marriage had gotten so bad that we
were living in different rooms in the
house looking married from the outside
but not behaving like married people we
were friendly with one another but there
was no intimacy there was nothing about
the beauty of marriage that was going on
I struggled with with guilt and I
struggled with alcohol and struggled
with pornography and I struggled with
solitude try to get away from it all
there was there was definitely something
missing in my life
we had a couple sessions with a
therapist and realized I had to deal
with my issues at that point she
suggested celebrate recovery Saddleback
Church didn't know what it was but I
thought you know at this point I'm gonna
I'm ready to try anything and from the
day I walked in there and I get
emotional here from the day I walked in
there I was home it was absolutely the
turning point in my life well it sounds
like that that this church and God has
intersected your lives and changed every
facet of your life big time
Abuk tony every year in marriage men's
group money everything I an honor each
other your family conflict resolution
the whole yeah yeah when we first got
married finances was my deal and it had
always been my deal it's something I
enjoyed I loved the spreadsheets I loved
the data Lisa really didn't care one way
or another at least that from my point
of view that's what it felt like I was
playing the credit card shuffle game
I was shuffling no payments doing all
this stuff and realized that was one of
the biggest stressors in my life that I
couldn't do this anymore and now that my
relationship was coming back together
tackling this financial piece and maybe
getting her on board to how this thing
was this Dave Ramsey program will has
looked to me like the key
the people that were sharing their
debt-free screams and the relationships
that people were we're talking about was
what I wanted in my relationship I was a
little hesitant when Scott came home and
told me about FPU and asked me to join
with him but I agreed to move forward
with this because we were having success
and all the other issues that we were
dealing with we got to the episode about
the free spirit and the nerd and finally
I realized that I wasn't just a weirdo
and and he was the right one
I was the free spirit and he was the
nerd and that was okay
and it really opened up the possibility
of my participating in the finances so
as we began to do the budget Scott began
to express to me that he valued my free
spirit Ness and how I brought fun to
what we could do with money all of a
sudden we were back together on a
crusade as we're going through FPU our
kids started to see this stuff our
middle son Aaron who was in his early
20s was asking a lot of questions about
it we said that why don't you come to
the class come join the class with us
and so Lisa Coe coordinated with me that
class and we had Aaron and Lise in the
class and it was fantastic it was just
so great to see them not only get the
questions answered that he had for me
but to hear from somebody other than me
and to buy-in it into it as much as I
bought it to it and it was it was it was
great to see Aaron at this point was not
a practicing Christian and and had a
great many doubts about God one of the
biggest influences over this two-year
period of time was watching his father
meet God and the influence that having
God in his life made not only to him but
in our relationship a year before Aaron
was married he came to Christ and and he
started his marriage off knowing what we
didn't know until we did Dave Ramsey I
think FPU for for him was a first step
in in finding a relationship with God
the biggest thing was that just the
example they were able to be to us as we
were starting our marriage like they
were very candid and you know these are
the things that happen when you don't
have a plan when you don't have a budget
learn from us and so that was that was
great that was great experience having
been through what we went through with
our relationship where for two years we
argued out right in front of our
children I was very very concerned about
the impact that that had had we were
receiving light and it was shining
through us to our children and they
remarked on it and it gave me
such encouragement to know that it
wasn't just the storms that they would
remember but coming through the storms
and being on the other side all of a
sudden it seemed all of a sudden
although it had been a difficult couple
of years we were debt-free and Scott
came to me and said what do you think
about going to Nashville and and being
on Dave show and I thought what better
way to celebrate and share what we've
done with other people and the debt-free
scream was just a scream it was so much
fun
to do we're debt-free
that's a good one that is so good after
our debt free screen we went on with our
life and continued with the budget
continue with the Dave Ramsey FPU
principles it's been nothing but
windfalls
since we've seen stock options we've
seen a better contract increase in pay
we bought a new car we were going on a
cruise celebrating our 30th anniversary
and given more than we ever imagined we
could it've we've shared and it's that's
that's been the best part of it is to be
able to share our wealth
you